what are five simple things that people
can do to protect themselves from from
hackers who's a password manager install
an antivirus or consult with an I.T
company that has cyber security
expertise or a cyber security company
using RFID blocking wallet uh and
potentially if you want to be extra safe
use a key fob that has an RFID shield on
it that way your key fob doesn't work
outside of that Shield be careful with
the websites that you're visiting if the
browser is telling you the site looks
unsafe then it's probably unsafe you
know if you're told otherwise make sure
who who's telling you otherwise is
legitimate
be careful I mean just use your common
sense if something looks too good to be
true it probably is